[Music]
[Applause]
yes Todd the professor is with us all
right Dr Tom Smith BYU professor of
wildlife Sciences uh doc thank you for
helping us uh I may have misspoke
yesterday of what you do when you
encounter a bear so if you could give us
sort of what the philosophy is and maybe
how it's changed over the years of what
you do when you encounter a bear
yeah thank you uh for having me my
pleasure
um well the main thing I like to
emphasize to people is number one in
this pre this is before any of the
advice on how to deal with a bear
one-on-one is you really have no
business in Bear Country without some
way of dealing with them meaning that
you need to have bear spray or a firearm
or some kind of deterrent because if you
have a bear that's determined to cause
you harm you you've got to be able to
tell it no just uh one-on-one that's not
gonna happen so when we see the kind of
desperate things people do such as run
from bears climb trees or even lay down
and play dead that's almost always
because they don't have any option for
dealing with the bear other than that
okay so so number one I wouldn't go in
Bear Country I've been in there for 30
some years I've dealt with thousands of
bears I just don't give that option up
to bears that if one of them gets
menacingly aggressive I've got to be
able to stop it so that's number one
number two uh the simplest thing you can
do which is without any deterrence just
in in the case you don't have them as
hike with buddies so like two or more
people Yellowstone Park says at least
three my data from North America say
you're pretty safe with two but but that
means you just have to be able to outrun
one of the two other guys with you is
what you're saying doc that like that or
use your underpowered gun to shoot one
of them in the leg
okay but I was fishing in Montana and
they have the Bears there they do yeah
so
um if I encountered a brown bear or a
black bear is there a difference in what
I'm supposed to do
well certainly
um so let's say after all you've done
you you're with your friends you're
fishing along a river but you're
scattered out a little bit
um and all of a sudden here comes a
brown bear or a black bear number one
thing again is to ready your deterrent
get your bear spray off your hip and
then I would
start backing away from the Bear get
away from it give it some space in many
many instances the bearish is trying to
go somewhere and you're in its way so
get out of its way and then continue to
move don't run but don't just stand
there and the reason why I say never
stand there is because let's say on
another occasion you you're around a
corner you get your Rod out you're Fly
Fishing uh you don't know that there's
not a bison carcass in that Creek and
the Bears on it you don't know that
there's not two Cubs hiding up in the
brush you standing there saying hey bear
hey bear don't hurt me or something like
that that just aggravates that you need
to get away from it so so get away from
the bear but do it you know in a
determined manner but not with speed
which one climbs a tree doc
well I'll tell you what I've seen brown
bears up to 30 40 feet in the tree so so
that strategy is a really bad one I I
looked at yeah I looked at uh about 150
tree climbers and we can lay it to rest
the the trying to out climb Olympic tree
climbers is probably a bad strategy for
you and your Waiters with a fishing rod
can I yell at them
oh you certainly can and that will most
times precipitate a charge and then an
attack can I oh no that they will attack
me if I yell at them yeah that that sort
of uh sharp uh startle can can trigger a
that kind of response I had I had an
experience with the commodity bear are
you familiar with the the spirit bear
yes and he was about uh 10 to 15 feet
away from me accidentally yeah but he
was interested in the salmon that were
spawning I was in British Columbia and
he just looked at me
now if you if he wanted to kill me he
could have but he just looked and he I
think he was curious but he and he might
have recognized me as being on TV and uh
you know being an Adam Sandler movies
doc but he decided he was going to go
eat the salmon so he didn't care
he had other things on his mind
I think I
think about this is important and people
have a hard time wrapping their mind
around it
um animals like bears and you were
talking about wolves earlier the real
narrow in their focused on what they eat
and humans typically are not part of
that so they see you and they're kind of
surprised and they're trying to size
things up but that's a good time just to
move on back to your question on black
and brown so a black bear should never
approach you
um and when you
you know show some aggressive behavior
to it hopefully with some friends it
should run if it doesn't run now you've
got a problem
should I say you go what what is the
most dangerous experience you've ever
encountered
doctor with two tranquilized bears and
place the land and I said I said to him
these two are going parachuting with no
parachute in about one minute because
they were coming out of the drug so that
was not cool
also one other one I chased a bear Into
the Woods I I don't know I was junior
team member and they said go after that
one it was a young bear and I went after
it and it was probably three or four
hundred pounds and when I got in there I
realized you know that's that's that's
really still a very big animal so that
was a stupid thing to do I don't know
what they thought I was going to do is
run it back to them they had guns they
were going to tranquilize but yeah I
won't do that again
uh well it's great to talk to you thanks
yeah yeah thanks for uh enlightening us
on what to do when we encounter a bear
you know next time that I encounter a
bear maybe I'll just call you when I've
encountered the bear and then you could
probably you know help me put it on
speakerphone and then uh you could guide
me to safety my Line's always open or
else the backup is I'll read about you
and thank you talk I appreciate it put
it in the database all right maybe you
could speak uh you know at my funeral uh
he is uh Dr Tom Smith BYU professor of
wildlife Sciences thank you doc thanks
for joining us okay there you go yes so
I think if I could give the cliffs notes
version of it what we learned about how
to handle a bear encounter is don't put
yourself in that position in the first
place that's sort of what it sounds like
yeah